As you step into the forest, pause.
Still yourself.
The forest captivates the imagination,...
...permeates into the myths and beliefs of every culture.
There are trees standing to this day that sheltered our ancestors from the rain...
...as they shared their stories and fires 5,000 years ago;...
...trees that have stood through the rise and fall of empires and civilizations.
Forests measure the passing of the year with vibrant green growth,...
...the fall of leaves orange and brown.
They live on as generations come and go,...
...waiting as the world changes all around.
But the heart of the forest beats slowly, unchanging.
Walk into a forest today anywhere in the world...
...and share the same quiet awe that others experience.
We are connected to forests.
We must look after their future.